And compelling information from police.
And a crucial witness
revealing new details
about the savage murders
of four university students.
Yesterday,
we saw furniture from the crime scene
in Moscow, Idaho,
being loaded into trucks and taken away.
CNN's Gary
Tuchman is on the scene
for us as investigators
try to work out
exactly what happened inside
that building
in the probable cause affidavit.
A Moscow,
Idaho, police
corporal says after finding the victims
who were killed,
I noticed what appeared to be a tan
leather knife sheath laying on the bed.
The Idaho State Lab later
located a single source of male
DNA left on the button
snap of the knife sheath.
Police say the DNA is suspect Brian
Kielburger.
This is the house
where the college students were killed.
According to the affidavit,
when police arrived.
They went through that door
with the Christmas wreath is
on the second floor.
To the right of the door is the bedroom.
Rosanna Cano
and Ethan Chapman were killed
also on the second floor to the left
in the back of the house.
According to the affidavit,
that's where the witness DNA was.
And finally, on the third floor,
you see that window right there?
According to the affidavit,
that's where Caylee Gonsalves
and Madison Morgan were.
And that's where the knife sheath
was found based on the affidavit.
It appears
Brian Kielburger
has been near this house
many times before.
The affidavit
indicating Coburg, her
cell phone signal was detected
12 times
near the house
over a period of five months
prior to the murders.
All of these occasions, except for one,
occurred in the late evening
and early morning hours
of their respective days.
It wouldn't necessarily
be suspicious of Brian Coburg
or drove past this house
12 times over five months.
If these were busy or prominent streets
or streets
on the way to another neighborhood.
But to come here
you have to be looking for
these roads are winding,
they're narrow, they're curvy.
In short,
it seems difficult
to accidentally end up here.
The affidavit states
that one of the students who survived
with the initials
DM heard crying
and opened her door three times.
She saw a figure clad in black clothing
and a mask that covered the person's
mouth and nose walking towards her.
Diem described
the figure as five, ten or taller male,
not very muscular,
but athletically built
with bushy eyebrows.
The male walked past him
as she stood in a frozen, shocked face.
The male walked towards the back
sliding glass door.
Dean locked herself in a room
after seeing the male
DM did not state that she recognize
the male.
This turned out
to be critical information
because in November 25th,
shortly after the murders, Moscow
police asked law enforcement agencies
to be on the lookout
for a white Hyundai Elantra
that had been seen near the murder site.
Four days later, police
discovered a white Elantra
in this parking
lot just across the state line
in Pullman, Washington.
According to the affidavit,
it was registered
a coworker
who lived up the stairs
in this townhouse complex
Police acquired his driver's
license information,
and they say, according to the affidavit,
that it was consistent
with the description of the man
she saw who was wearing black clothing
and a mask.
The affidavit does
not contain information about motive
or if the alleged killer knew
any of the victims,
but authorities could very well
have leads about those topics.
That are not being publicly released yet.
Next Thursday,
in this courthouse
behind me, Brian Cobourg
will have another hearing.
This will be a status hearing to discuss
scheduling in the case
within the next couple of weeks.
He will be arraigned
where he'll likely issue a plea.
Let's bring in now Tracy Walter.
She is a former CIA officer
and a former FBI special agent.
Tracy, so the D.C. you.
So I want to ask you
about all of the things
that we've been learning
about the suspect.
But I do want to caution viewers
that there are some graphic details
that could come up in our conversation.
So I do want you to be braced for that.
So, Tracy, what does it tell you
that the suspect
was allegedly around the house
multiple times before the killings?
Well, thank you so much
for having me, Fredricka.
So what that does tell me
is that he was indeed
unfortunately stalking these victims,
because what's also important
is the absence
of cellular information
during that timeframe
of the killings that you mentioned.
So to have your cell phone
pinging around that area
when you don't live in that vicinity,
his vicinity in
WSU would have hit on a different
cell phone tower.
12 pings in the timeframe leading up
to the killings, in the months
leading up to the killings that signify
But what's also significant
is that there was no cell phone
activity for 2 hours.
Is it your suspicion
that there was some sort of interaction?
I mean, you are using the word stalking.
There was some interest
that he allegedly had in these victims.
Do you feel
like there
it may have been precipitated by
some interaction?
I mean,
how would you
examine the evidence to discern that?
So one of the best ways
to get information to discern
that would actually be social media.
You know, had
he had any interactions
just in terms
of liking things
on their social media or vice versa.
I do believe
and I've always kind
of aspired to this theory
and agreed with this theory
that he came into contact,
but it was most likely brief.
It may not have even piqued
the radar of the victims.
And I believe
that's probably how he selected
one to all of them as his target.
So social media
would really come into play
there as well as witness
testimony of any interactions
And then investigators clearly
are probably still poring over
all the social media
presence of any and all of of the victims
and I recall hearing from
from many
who have looked
at a lot of the Instagram.
There was a lot of information there.
There's a lot of activity
that has been posted by these victims.
So police say coworker
he also cleaned his car
very carefully
and also took care of disposing of trash
at his parents house. So
we know that he had been
studying criminology.
What does all of this
tell you about his awareness
you know,
perhaps using information
he has learned as a student,
I mean, preparing himself for
not just the crime, allegedly,
but for afterwards.
You know what's fascinating about that?
Rodriguez, I'm
actually an adjunct faculty
of criminal justice at Texas
Christian University.
And it's surprising to me
how much he didn't learn it necessarily.
The reality is this
We teach all students
trash becomes public property
once it's out there on the street.
And so the fact
that he was trying to circumnavigate
that and place it into neighbors
trash cans
is a bit shocking to me, quite frankly.
And then also the fact that he was doing
so in the reports
I read on CNN at 4 a.m., you know, FBI,
myself included, we were on surveillance
all hours of the day.
So he had to have known
or suspected
that he would have been watched.
Had he done something like that.
I do believe that he is arrogant
and has an ego
big enough
to think that he is smarter
than everyone else
and that he had outsmarted the system.
Mm hmm. Yeah. And as you as you
really paint
the picture on that
it makes me rethink
the whole cell phone pings.
Obviously, that is something
that you would learn to
as a student of criminology,
all of the things
that would be indicators
that eventually can be evidence
of your whereabouts and how.
He probably should have known that,
but I guess didn't.
So a roommate in the house
identified by the document as D.M.
said a masked person
walked right past her
as she opened up the door.
And, you know,
she recalls the the bushy eyebrows,
but that he didn't harm her,
but that it was described
that she kind of froze.
I mean, what does that moment tell you?
About
maybe is that the element of surprise
or is there anything about familiarity
or what do you dissect from that moment?
So I just dissect a couple of
things from that moment.
First of all,
a lot of people are being quite harsh
to that young lady,
and we don't know what we would do
in a situation like that.
I truly
think that he probably didn't see her.
I believe that she saw him.
I looked at the floorplan
of the house again
just to kind of figure out
what that angle would have looked like.
I believe that after
he most likely killed Zina and Ethan,
he was just looking to get straight
out of that house.
And if she just had her or her door
just cracked a little bit,
he very well may not have seen her.
And I think that she completely froze at
that point.
So in my opinion, that's
what happened there.
But I do
believe coworker was probably familiar
with the house
and that he had to go
all the way up to the third floor for two
of the victims.